ah les tunisiens se sont réveillés ce
matin avec une chaîne de télévision en
moins la haute autorité de l'audiovisuel
a affirmé hier soir nessma tv pour
exercice illégal de son activité une
décision qui intervient alors que le
fondateur du média nabil karoui a été
remis en liberté et placé sous contrôle
judiciaire en algérie la correspondance
à tunis de ben hassen chébili une
nouvelle affaire judiciaire qui
éclabousse nabil karoui le président du
parti à cannes dont le ca la tête de la
chaîne de télévision nessma l'homme
d'affaires a pris mercredi la fermeture
de son antenne par laika la haute
autorité indépendant de la communication
audiovisuelle en cause des transmissions
sans licence de diffusion après de
multiples mises en garde de la part des
autorités tunisiennes écouter la chaîne
nessma tv à retarder le règlement de son
statut juridique depuis 2014 et ce
malgré les appels lancés et les efforts
de l'aica à travers de nombreuses
correspondances et réunion depuis 2014
qui l'avait obligé à prendre la décision
d'arrêter les procédures de règlement en
juillet 2018 la haute instance a précisé
que cette fermeture était également
motivé par des soupçons de corruption
financière et administrative en cause
également l influence politique exercée
sur la chaîne par celui qui reste aux
yeux de l'état tunisien le chef d'un des
principaux partis d'opposition en 2019
like avait déjà procédé à la saisie des
équipements de nessma tv pour des
raisons similaires accompagnées par les
forces de l'ordre la haute autorité a
procédé mercredi à l'arrêt de diffusion
de la chaîne tout en invitant ses
collaborateurs à évacuer les lieux lancé
en 2007 nessma tv avait pour objectif de
proposer des contenus inédits à
destination de la diaspora maghrébine en
europe on peut donc parler d'un vrai
coup de filet audiovisuel puisqu'outre
la chaîne de la ville car oui d'autres
médias comme hannibal tv ou radio coran
ont été sommés également de suspendre
leur diffusion et ce jusqu'à
régularisation de leur situation